à l'examen des articles précédemment
réservé et à l'amendement au numéro 7
tendant à insérer un article additionnel
avant l'article 1er
sur cet amendement a parlé d'un monsieur
soeur
merci monsieur le président tout d'abord
nous sommes heureux de saluer monsieur
le garde des sceaux ainsi d'ailleurs que
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois qui sont donc revenus de leur
périple vers poitiers nous avons
regretté hier que vous ne faisiez pas là
lorsqu'il eut la décla la discussion
générale portant sur ce grave sujet de
l' irresponsabilité pénale je rappelle à
monsieur le ministre que il qu'il s'agit
d'une semaine gouvernementale donc le
gouvernement était maître de l'ordre du
jour de cette semaine gouvernementale le
sénat n'aurait pas pu s'opposer à ce que
les choses ont été
organisées de telle manière qu'il n'y
ait pas concomitance entre ce débat
important au sénat et l'annoncent
d'états généraux dont vous voyez bien
monsieur le président qui le se situe
dans une période
particulière c'est à dire je ne suis pas
sûr que l'arrivée de ces états généraux
alors que tant de choses ont été déjà
décidée voter tant de loi discutée
présenter promulguée eh bien je ne suis
pas sûr que cela soit très logique de le
faire en fin de mandat en période
électorale mais cela vous l'avez souvent
entendu longuement monsieur le garde des
sceaux et je pense qu en votre for
intérieur
vous y pensez constamment bien alors il
me reste très peu de temps en raison de
ce nouveau règlement extrêmement funeste
monsieur le président mes chevaux
précise que je ferai une inspiration peg
donc il s'agit pour le moment de la
reprise d'un amendement
définissant le discernement que nous
avions présentées lors de l'examen d'une
proposition de loi de madame goulet en
mai dernier je crois donc nous l'avons
déjà défendu monsieur le président merci
chers collègues après cette belle
défense am la rapporteure l'avis de la
commission merci monsieur le président
est bien et comme la fois précédente mon
cher collègue la vie et de la commission
mais vous le savez est défavorable là la
question du discernement est certes
importante mais ne pose pas de
difficulté particulière et il n'y a pas
de motif d'insérer dans la loi une
définition sur une notion que tout le
monde connaît et maîtrise parfaitement
la vie reste défavorable merci monsieur
le ministre
merci monsieur le président c'est pas si
c'est une belle défense et pour partie
au réquisitoire
à mon endroit alors je vais d'abord
présenté au sénat toutes mes excuses
j'ai d'abord présenté je vais d'abord
j'avais prévenu le sénat d'ailleurs
n'est pas anormal que le garde des
sceaux et était aux côtés du président
de la république
pour l' annonce des états généraux de la
justice d'ailleurs il y avait à mes
côtés madame guigou madame la ministre
guigou et je sais que
l'une d'entre vous a évoqué hier une
campagne électorale
on pas que madame la ministre guigou
fasse campagne pour le président de la
république qui au demeurant n'est pas
candidat il est également monsieur le
président de la commission des lois du
sénat qui était à mes côtés madame v
rien également j'ai la faiblesse de
penser qu'ils ne viennent pas non plus
faire la campagne électorale du
président de la république qui je le
rappelle à cet instant n'est pas
candidat il y avait également un certain
nombre d'autres parlementaires
je vais vous dire dans quel état on se
retrouve
monsieur le sénateur et vous allez
comprendre si le président de la
république ne travaille plus on dira ah
il est en campagne si le travail
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure on dit
aussi les temps compagne alors voyez
c'est compliqué de s'en sortir ces états
généraux de la justice c'est quelque
chose d'extrêmement important
dans un premier temps nous avons
souhaité restaurer la justice avec un
budget exceptionnel mettre en oeuvre un
certain nombre de mesures vous les
connaissez l ont été notamment débattu
ici et dans un deuxième temps il est
question de moderniser la justice nous
avons choisi le futuroscope je lui ai
déjà dit et non pas les grottes de
lascaux pas ce que nous envisageons bien
sûr la justice du futur alors hier
madame la sénatrice de la gontrie vous
avez cru devoir dire que j'étais en
campagne aux côtés du président de la
république et vous il ya il ya quelques
jours il ya quelques jours je vous ai vu
aux côtés de madame hidalgo juste
derrière elle vous étiez sein toutes les
deux de vos écharpe tricolore vous
annonciez je crois la police municipale
moi je n'ai pas pensé une seconde je
n'ai pas pensé une seconde mais pour ce
sujet ou pour un autre laissez-moi
terminé je n'ai pas pensé une seconde
que vous étiez en campagne pas du tout
j'ai pensé que vous étiez là pour
défendre votre territoire d'ailleurs si
vous aviez été en compagne et ses côtés
serait plus à 4% voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire tout ça ce sont des polémiques
stériles je vais enfin répondre mais pas
du tout je vous ai expliqué qu'il est
bien normal que le garde des sceaux sont
aux côtés du président de la république
pour les états généraux de la justice et
je suis ravi de voir que j'ai pu vous
manqué et je veux préciser ici à la
représentation nationale mais elle le
sait que les articles que je porte nous
allons seulement commencé à les évoquer
dans quelques secondes et vous l'avez
fait d'ailleurs monsieur le sénateur sur
alors je vais vous dire votre amendement
vous l'avez déjà proposé il a déjà été
rejetée par votre assemblée le 25 mai
dernier il est à mon sens totalement
inopérant et le gouvernement présents
ici par ma personne est défavorable à
cet amendement
merci monsieur le ministre la présidente
assassi pour explication de vote oui
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux moi je veux pas entrer
dans la polémique
campagne électorale ou pas accompagné
simplement rappelé que nous avons dit
est ce que j'ai dit particulièrement
fière ce que nous avons
regretté enfin ce que nous avons dit
c'est que simplement les états généraux
de la justice n'était pas inscrire à
votre agenda ou à celui du président de
la république depuis ce week-end et donc
qu'il aurait fallu effectivement
reporter ou
inscrire à un autre moment l'examen de
ce texte d'autant que hier cela s'est
doublée de l'absence aussi de monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur et je ne
reviens pas sur les qualités de monsieur
feno ministre chargé des relations avec
le parlement il n'y a pas de souci de ce
point de vue là mais voyez il y avait la
conjonction de deux absences et pour des
raisons différentes mais j'ai la naïveté
de croire que ces initiatives de ce nom
pas été inscrite je le répète aux
agendas la veille pour le lendemain
merci donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement on inventerait
merci monsieur le président je rassure
les collègues je n'ai pas l'intention de
polémiquer avec le garde je parle de
l'amendement
je remercie le collègue richard de
saluer mon propos non simplement la
définition ladislas du discernement est
quelque chose de très important c'est
tellement important que nous l'avons
fait lorsque nous avons débattu de la du
code pénal des mineurs
parce que c'est quelque chose qui est
définie d'un point de vue
jurisprudentielle est pas dans le code
donc
notre collègue muriel jourda a balayé
cet argument d'un revers de main mais je
pense que nous avons tort il est
important de rappeler nal que nous
sachions de quoi nous parlons et c'est
bien l'objet de cette définition disons
que le discernement c'est la conscience
de l'acte commis de ses conséquences et
des capacités en apprécier la nature et
la portée et ça évite du coup les
interprétations jurisprudentielles
excessive donc c'est très utile et voilà
le sens de notre amendement que nous
serions heureux que vous décidez de
voter comme dans le code pénal des
mineurs merci cher collègue monsieur
surnom de maisons voire amendement sets
avec deux avis défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée à
l'article 1er deux amendements
identiques tout d'abord le 37 la
présidente à ça si oui merci monsieur le
président on vouloir responsabilité les
malades mentaux c'est faire peu de cas
d'amanda malade mental lorsque son
discernement était aboli il n'en a pas
conscience comme il n'en a pas comme il
n'en a pas conscience quand ils
consomment de la drogue ou de l'alcool
en cas d'abolition on est en présence
d'un individu qui a perdu ses facultés
peu importe pourquoi car quand il a et
car quand il agit il n'est pas apte à
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé que cela
soit temporaire de change rien au
problème si l'article 122-1 du code
pénal est restée intacte comme le
recommandait le rapport un beau rayon il
n'en reste pas moins que le dispositif
aujourd'hui proposé vient soutenir de
manière peut-être plus présentable
l'idée selon laquelle un individu dont
le discernement était aboli n'est pas
forcément irresponsable pénalement par
l'intermédiaire d'un mécanisme de chez
fautif il s'agit de créer un nouvel état
entre altération et abolition du
discernement appelé abolition temporaire
du discernement on vient fragmenté
l'état de conscience et d'inconscience
ce que ce qui ne fait pas sens légiférer
en ce sens ce serait oublier que les
comportements de prise de drogue ou
d'alcool ne sont pas nécessairement
fautif mais qu'ils peuvent être non pas
la cause de l'abolition du discernement
mais la conséquence de cette abolition
ainsi la notion d'abolition temporaire
choisi pour prendre en compte ces
situations n'étant rien selon nous
satisfaisante en outre ce dispositif
pour sur un second objectif tout aussi
critiquable l'instauration d'un
véritable procès dans les cas précités
mais quelle est la pertinence d'un
procès de l'aliéner quel est le sens
d'une audience pensée pour un délinquant
rationnelle lorsqu un fou et jugé cela
est me semble-t-il symptomatique de la
mise en oeuvre d'une politique pénale
compassionnel à l'égard des victimes et
des lois de circonstance pour satisfaire
l'opinion publique
merci chers collègues 71 monsieur
benarroch
oui monsieur le président merci j'ai eu
l'occasion hier lors de la présentation
de la motion de développer très
largement notre avis sur ce sujet qui
est le même que celui qui vient d'être
défendu par la présidente à ça si il est
vrai que le texte tel qu'il était prévu
par le gouvernement
nous semble excessivement dangereux dans
le sens où il fragilisé a cost est
incontestablement pour nous l'élément
intentionnel de l'infraction qui est un
principe fondamental du droit pénal tout
en ne répondant pas l'objectif qui était
poursuivi par le législateur
en fait nous pose encore la question est
aujourd'hui de savoir sur quelles études
ou sur quelle concertation
nous avions pu le gouvernement avait pu
avancer pour se permettre des quartiers
l'irresponsabilité dans le cas où
l'abolition du discernement était dû à
une prise volontaire de substances
psychoactives mais la présidente assassi
via d'expliquer je partage totalement sa
démonstration
dans ce sens nous saluons effectivement
le fait que la commission est en
conformité avec les travaux que nous
avions déjà mené d'ailleurs au printemps
dernier écarté cette possibilité
donc effectivement le texte qui nous est
présenté aujourd'hui nous paraît être
préférable à celui qui avait été
originellement introduit par le
gouvernement dans la loi toutefois je
les ai également dit hier cette
réécriture nous correspond pas non plus
à la position de notre groupe puisque
pour nous le renvoi possible de voir le
juge de fond ne correspond
essentiellement qu'à répondre à une
demande qui est celle des victimes
d'avoir un procès nous comprenons bien
cette demande et nous entendons bien le
fait que le besoin d'un procès doit être
pris en considération
mais nous pensons également que
l'audience en chambre d'instruction qui
est collégiale qui se concentre sur le
question de la responsabilité pénale du
mis en cause qui est déjà public qui
était un contradictoires qui permettait
à la présence des victimes et des
avocats des parties civiles nous semble
être aujourd'hui la bonne solution à
développer améliorer mais la bonne et
nous demandons donc dans ce cadre là la
suppression de cet article 1er merci
chers collègues marc à porter
merci monsieur le président ma chère
collègue la présidence à ça si je
partage votre opinion sur le fait que le
droit pénal ne doit pas s'éteindre droit
compassionnel je pense que le droit
pénal et les instances pénales sont le
droit de la société et de l'ordre public
et qu'effectivement c'est ainsi qu'il
faut les saisir pour autant pour que la
société se saisissent de cette ex
saisissent de ce droit encore faut-il
qu'elle le comprennent et il me semble
que la solution qui a été choisie par la
commission qui n'est pas celle du
gouvernement mais nous y reviendrons qui
est de pouvoir avoir effectivement un
procès public pas nécessairement
d'ailleurs pour prononcer la
responsabilité pénale de la personne
dont on pense que précisément elle était
en attente de l'abolition du
discernement mais que ce procès public
puisse avoir lieu paraît effectivement
de bonne justice c'est une solution qui
est à l' avantage de ne pas modifier les
caddies responsabilité pénale est de ne
pas
je dirais toucher à ce droit dont on
sait qu'il est extrêmement délicat et
nous avons eu l'occasion de nous a
expliqué hier durant la discussion
générale donc c'est une solution qui a
été adopté par la commission qui avait
déjà été adopté par le sénat au mois de
mai dernier sur le rapport de notre
collègue nathalie goulet les la vie vous
comprendrez à la fois de l'amendement de
madame présenté par madame assassi mais
également présentés par monsieur
benarroch est défavorable merci monsieur
ministre
le gouvernement a déposé un amendement
pour établir l'article premier dans sa
rédaction adoptée par l'assemblée
nationale dans ces conditions je suis
évidemment opposés à ces amendements de
suppression je voudrais redire un tout
petit mot madame la présidente abbassi
hier dans l'expression vous avez su vous
avez parlé de mépris du gouvernement
vous avez le droit de l'exprimer mais ça
n'est pas une réalité je pense que
mon attitude
au sénat
l'ouverture qui est la mienne depuis je
suis ministre de la justice
la passion je mets dans les débats
dois me semble-t-il mais vous êtes
naturellement libre de de vous interdire
de pensée qui a du mépris voilà je veux
simplement terminer par ça parce que
c'est un mot qui est bien excessif au
fond
j'ai expliqué tout à l'heure pour quelle
raison j'étais absente j'ai présenté mes
excuses elles sont évidemment sincère à
l'impossible nul n'est tenu et je n'ai
pas le don d'ubiquité
mais pour le reste madame n'y a pas de
mépris du tout et je ne pense pas que
vous ayez pu le constater à un moment
quelconque de mes interventions même si
nos débats et nos échanges et c'est bien
moins dans un pays de libertés sont
parfois vifs
voilà mais c'est la vie vivacité
indispensable au débat démocratique a
semble-t-il le ministre
[Musique]
dans une police municipale s'est pas à
vous que je m'adresse
mais si on devait faire la somme des
comportements un peu
comment dire pour ne pas utiliser le mot
méprisant un peu anachronique du
gouvernement à l'égard du du sénat je
dois vous dire que la liste serait
longue et et je pense que ce sentiment
que j'ai est partagée sur tous les bancs
de notre assemblée donc ce n'est
vraiment pas un propos simplement à
votre égard mais ce ministre merci chers
collègues donc je mets souvent à
l'amendement les deux amendements 37 et
71 identique avec deux avis défavorables
qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont
pas adopté l'amendement 86 du
gouvernement monsieur le ministre
monsieur le président c'est un
amendement que je pourrais appeler
l'amendement capitale ont de quoi
s'agit-il un homme responsable
consomment des produits stupéfiants dans
le but est dans le but exclusivement de
commettre ultérieurement un crime
après la commission de ce crime des
experts disent de lui qu'il n'est pas
responsable qu'il n'a pas de
discernement et bien nous nous estimons
que la prise volontaire de produits
stupéfiants
pardon pour cette familiarité dans le
but de se donner du courage est un acte
qui s'assimile au crime lui-même et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons qu'ils soient pénalisés
naturellement il faut que l'intéressé
ait recouvré ensuite son discernement
parce qu'on ne juge pas les fous et
qu'il me soit permis de dire que je
conteste avec l'énergie la plus farouche
les reproches qui nous sont faits quant
à ce texte d'abord parce que les états
étrangers comme l'espagne par exemple
connaissent cette disposition ensuite
parce qu'elle est conforme aux principes
fondamentaux de notre droit et elle
respecte l'exigence d'un élément moral
et à ce titre je veux vous rappeler ici
que cette disposition a été validé par
le conseil d'état voilà sur cet article
premier dont je souhaite
qu'ils soient naturellement
rétabli est adopté tel qu'il l'a été par
l'assemblée nationale
je le redis quelqu'un de responsable
prendre des produits stupéfiants pour
commettre un attentat terroriste
cet exemple on le connaît on le
connaître en europe il perd la raison à
raison de cette consommation de produits
stupéfiants mais l'intention n'était pas
de se faire plaisir ce n'était pas un
moment festif c'était pour commettre un
crime et bien nous estimons que s'il a
consommé dans un état de conscience
naturellement il faut qu'ils soient
responsables quand il commet cette
infraction de consommation de produits
stupéfiants
alors il doit être condamné comme
l'auteur du crime le sénat a proposé en
remplacement une disposition dont je dis
ici qu'elle me paraît tout à fait
contestable
en effet vous souhaiter imposer un juge
d'instruction
qui estime que le discernement d'une
personne était aboli de la renvoyer
devant la juridiction de jugement dans
le cas où l'abolition résulte du fait
même de la personne
c'est l'exemple de quelqu'un qui pend
des produits stupéfiants qui commettent
un crime il est jugé irresponsable nous
nous souhaitons naturellement c'est
notre article 2 qu'il soit jugé pour la
consommation de produits stupéfiants
quand elle a les conséquences délétères
que nous avons vu dans un certain nombre
de dossiers et la commission souhaite en
réalité qu'à compter du moment où le
manque la perte de discernement résulte
de la consommation de produits
psychotropes par exemple alors il faut
renvoyer devant la cour d'assises sans
laisser le soin au juge ou à la chambre
de l'instruction d'ailleurs d'examiner
cette question alors ce qui est
contestable dans cet amendement me
semble-t-il est dans cette façon
d'envisager les choses c'est qu'on prive
le juge d'une certaine liberté je
rappelle ici que jamais un juge n'est
tenu par une expertise jamais et
attention parce que c'est un grand
principe le juge en toute matière en
matière civile en matière pénale n'est
pas tenu par les conclusions d'un expert
il peut ne pas suivre les expertises
laisser cette liberté aux juges c'est la
première chose
la deuxième chose pardon mais j'ai
assisté dans ma carrière d'avocat à une
audience chambre de l'instruction telle
qu'elle existe et bien si vous voyez
quelqu'un qui a la lippe pendantes dans
le box
qui est incapable de comprendre les
choses
vous donnez de la justice une image qui
n'est pas une image extraordinaire et
loin s'en faut
m un homme
dans une situation où il peut être vu
par tout le monde
dans une espèce de curiosité parfois
malsaine ça n'est pas me semble-t-il à
l'honneur de notre justice il y à cette
audience de la chambre de l'instruction
certes certes
elle ne répond pas à toutes les
exigences et en particulier je pense aux
victimes bien sûr mais est ce que l'on
peut exposer un homme dans un box je
pense madame la rapporteure que sur ce
texte très précisément sur le reste on
est à peu près d'accord vous franchissez
cette ligne rouge que nous n'avons pas
voulu franchir au fond vous avez
quelqu'un dont on sait qu'il a perdu son
discernement et que l'on exposé à la
justice malgré tout que vous le vouliez
ou non alors que nous nous proposons
qu'en réalité sur le volet il a consommé
des produits stupéfiants ils soient
jugés et c'est bien normal parce que on
ne peut pas s'exonérer totalement d'une
responsabilité quand on a commis une
infraction qui est l'infraction de
consommation de produits stupéfiants
j'ajoute pas même la rapporteure quand
l'état de notre législation on peut pas
envisager un procureur de la république
dans notre pays qui renverrait
l'intéressé pour une consommation de
stupéfiants maximum de la peine encourue
un an ce serait indécent et donc les
procureurs de la république ne renvoie
pas dans cette hypothèse devant la
juridiction correctionnelle et on laisse
tomber c'est bien ça qu'il nous fallait
rectifier mais on ne peut pas à
rectifier en prenant le risque de
renvoyer un fou en audience de jugement
au motif que sa folie aurait des causes
exogènes
voilà la réalité causes exogènes alors
on le juge pour cette extranéité si
j'ose dire c'est à dire la consommation
de produits stupéfiants pas le reste
c'est évidemment impossible et à la
condition naturellement que l'intéressé
soit en mesure de comprendre un certain
nombre de choses pour avoir assisté à
une audience de cette nature je pense
que elle n'a aucune raison de s'exhiber
davantage je pense qu'on ne franchit pas
cette ligne là qu'on ne juge pas les
fous mais qu'on peut les juger pour la
période où il n'était pas fou et où en
toute connaissance de cause et sont les
éléments constitutifs de l'infraction
ils ont consommé des produits
stupéfiants
merci monsieur ministre amendement 8 en
discussion comme une soeur
notre amendement monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre vise à écrire est
pénalement responsable la personne qui a
volontairement provoqué une perte de
discernement aux fins de commettre
l'infraction
notamment par la consommation de
boissons alcooliques drôme toxiques de
stupéfiants de substances psychotropes
ou de substances ayant des effets
similaires cet amendement monsieur le
garde des sceaux nous l'avons présenté
exactement le même en mai lorsqu'il est
venu la proposition de loi de maintenant
vous voulez de monsieur sol le même et
quelle fut votre réaction
vous m'avez demandé je me souviens très
bien de le retirer
et je n'ai pas jamais compris pourquoi
où j'avais quelques idées remarquer
j'avais l'idée comme cet amendement est
très proche du vôtre que vous vouliez en
quelque sorte
attendre
votre texte pour que cet amendement il
fut inséré par vous même on va remarquer
bien qu'il aurait pu tout à fait être
adopté au mois de mai alors voilà nous
pensons que cet amendement
répond tout à fait aux nécessité de
prendre en compte cette situation où une
personne
décide finalement de
provoqué en lui même une perte de
discernement dans le dessin d'accomplir
un acte criminel dont nous le présentons
pour mémoire en quelque sorte ou bien
entendu nous voterons et s'il n'était
pas adoptée nous voterons le vôtre mais
vous voyez que quelquefois le parlement
peut avoir des idées
juste quelques fois un peu avant qu'elle
n'arrive dans l'initiative
gouvernementale cela vaut pour le
premier aligna nous ne sommes pas sûrs
de la pertinence du second merci chers
collègues marmara porter
merci monsieur le président oui vous
pouvez dés fois être d'accord
effectivement avec le monsieur ministre
de la justice cheikh collègues mais la
commission ne l'est pas la commission ne
l'est pas et j'avoue à quelques
difficultés à suivre le raisonnement qui
nous est présenté
de quoi parlons nous parlons nous nous
parlons de la situation effectivement
dans laquelle quelqu'un a des seins
absorbe des substances que l'on qualifie
de psycho actives et qui va ensuite
commettre l'infraction qu'il avait prévu
de connaître et à quelles fins il avait
absorbé ces substances
la proposition qui vous est faite
d'amendements du gouvernement consiste à
dire dans ces cas là il est tjrs et il
n'est pas irresponsable pénalement même
s'il était en état l'abolition du
discernement
et je vois mal calé d'ailleurs la
liberté du jeu puisqu'il n'est pas
irresponsable pénalement nous dit le
texte du gouvernement la proposition du
sénat et de dire si le jeu une
instruction pense que cette personne
était en état d'abolition du
discernement ou d'atténuation du
discernement il ne va pas lui même
prendre la décision mais il va renvoyer
devant le juge du fond pour que juges du
fond puisse apprécier la réalité de ce
discernement et aujourd'hui dans l'état
du droit il n'est pas impossible d'être
condamné dans la situation qui a été
décrite par monsieur le garde des sceaux
donc loi d'enlever de la liberté au juge
au contraire il me semble que la
décision de la commission qui est je le
rappelle ce qui a été voté par le sénat
au mois de mai dernier permettent aux
juges du fond de trancher véritablement
la réelle cette abolition ou de cette
année à cette annulation de discernement
et si comme nous dit monsieur le garde
des sceaux à l'audience sept personnes
étaient encore en état d'abolition du
discernement la lippe tendance comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le garde des
sceaux bien cette personne ne serait pas
jugée parce qu'on n'a jamais juger des
gens dans cet état donc il me semble que
la solution préconisée par la commission
est encore une fois que nous avions voté
au mois de mai dernier et celle qui
préserve à la fois la liberté du juge de
trancher mais également le fait que
puissent être condamnés une personne qui
a des seins a pu prendre des substances
psychoactives pour commettre une
infraction c'est donc évidemment un avis
défavorable sur ces deux amendements
merci monsieur le maire sur l'amendement
merci monsieur le président
monsieur sénateurs sueur
je suis ravi que nous soyons d'accord
mais ça n'est pas la première fois
et et vous avait anticipé mon propos ce
année je l'espère mon non plus pas la
dernière je rappelle que j'ai pris à
bras le corps la ppl billon je rappelle
que
le texte sur les conditions indignes a
été porté par monsieur le président de
la commission des lois du sénat et que
voilà nous avons adhéré à s'était fait
que vous même d'ailleurs je vous ai
reçus à la chancellerie que j'ai pris
déjà un certain nombre de vos
amendements alors vous aviez fait cette
proposition c'est vrai c'est pas que
j'ai souhaité mon emparé pour au fond
être le concepteur de cet amendement
dont je concède bien volontiers
la paternité qui n'est pas la mienne
mais
je suis pas resté depuis ses premiers
débats que vous évoquez ici au sein de
cette assemblée les deux pieds dans le
même sabot j'ai consulté les experts
psychiatres les représentants des cultes
les magistrats des universitaires des
avocats est effectivement ces
consultations est en fait j'ai pensé
bien sûr que cet amendement avait toute
sa place dans une rédaction qui peut
être différent qu'il y avait également
la mission lucho savinien dont je me
suis inspiré donc tout ça fait que nous
sommes à peu près d'accord et je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire je vous propose donc
de retirer votre amendement au profit de
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement je veux dire un tout petit
mot encore sur ce qui me chagrine pardon
sur cet aspect très précis du travail de
la commission des lois du sénat
il ya un principe auquel nous sommes
sans doute très très attaché c'est la
liberté du juge et je ne veux pas
que nous mettions le pied dans
l'entrebâillement de la porte pour dire
au fond qu'un avis experte al
devienne le guide absolue du juge qui
perdrait alors sa liberté
juridictionnelle pardon et au delà du
texte qui nous occupe aujourd'hui c'est
pour moi une question de principe
ça n'est pas parce que le psychiatre dit
que le juge doit suivre et si vous
voulez un certain nombre d'exemples
pardon on en a pu se tromper par le
passé je les tiens à la disposition du
sénat mais le sénat le sait parfaitement
donc attention à ça le juge doit avoir
cette liberté
au regard des travaux qui sont les
travaux experte au infiniment
respectable certes d'ailleurs pardon de
vous dire que parfois les experts
psychiatres divergent dans leur
conclusion est donc il faut laisser aux
juges à chaque fois la possibilité 2 et
ne pas imposer les choses voilà ce que
je demande
quant à la libye pendant que vous me
dites ça n'arrivera plus jamais mais moi
je les ai déjà vus là dépendantes et je
me dis que si ça devient automatique
nous la verrons encore et c'est ça le
danger et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis totalement contre cet amendement
pour toutes les questions j'évoque mais
avant de voter je vous supplie
l'impératif naturellement m interdit
lorsque je m'adresse à vous de repenser
cette chose est ce que l'on peut imposer
aux juges un travail experte al quel que
soit l'expertisé et attention parce que
les petits abandon en la matière en
traîne parfois les grands merci monsieur
le ministre dont je me revois
l'amendement 86 du gouvernement avec un
avis défavorable de la commission qui et
pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté
le même vote pour la retirer
l'amendement 8
d'accord d'accord bien sûr donc je mets
au voyage je mets au voilà maintenant
huit avec un avis défavorable de la
commission une demande de retrait du
gouvernement qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adossé jeu mais se voit l'article
1er qui est pour l'article 1er qui et
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
je maison vaut à l'article 1er bis qui
et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après cet article l'amendement 2
madame vous voyez merci monsieur le
président mes chers collègues cet
amendement très attendue par certains
professionnels du droit par des
associations a été votée en mai par le
sénat dans notre proposition de loi sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale
j'avais d'ailleurs accepté de le
retravailler à l'époque pour satisfaire
la commission ce que j'ai fais bien
volontiers et il avait reçu un avis
favorable avant d'être voté avec le
soutien de la présidente de la
délégation du droit des femmes qui est
la première co signataires de cet
amendement à nouveau et de sénateurs de
tous les bancs l'actualité judiciaire
nous a donné raison puisque valérie bako
qui avait été condamné à quatre ans de
prison dont un ferme est sorti libre
vendredi 25 juin 2021 le premier expert
psychiatrique du procès a expliqué que
la sphère valérie bako était une faille
de la société je le cite notre rôle de
société c'est d'empêcher sa le libre
arbitre de valérie bako est réduit néant
dans sa pensée elle n'est pas seule son
mari est toujours présent l'emprise
l'emprise insiste bien et permanente la
jonction persiste je ferme les
guillemets la victime ne peut plus
prendre de décisions raisonnables comme
toute personne qui n'a pas connu la
violence conjugale répétitif sur
plusieurs années que ce soit à travers
des insultes des critiques incessantes
des remarques désobligeantes des
comportements de mépris d'avilissement
d'asservissement de l'autre des
violences physiques et sexuelles
toutes ces attaques touchent l'intégrité
psychique de la victime qui devient
alors prisonnière de la situation
qu'elle subit ce sont en fait des actes
de torture mentale de par ses
agissements le conjoint violent portent
atteinte aux principes de respect de la
dignité de la personne humaine
aujourd'hui rares sont des cas dans
lesquels la victime de violences
conjugales arrive à se défaire de
l'emprise exercée sur elle par son
bourreau en effet ces victimes ne
portent que trop rarement plainte
cet état de soumission et de danger de
mort permanent vécu pendant des années
peut entraîner un comportement extrême
la plupart du temps une des issues de la
sortie de cet enfer conjugale vous le
savez c'est le suicide de la victime
dans des câbles très très rare la
victime se retourne contre le conjoint
car elle n'a pas d'autre issue que de le
tuer pour ne pas nourrir pour pas mourir
pardon c'est elle ou moi le sénat avait
fait preuve de courage et je le sais
notre prise de position était très
attendue par les soutiens des victimes
de violences conjugales combien de
victimes sont dans cette situation
le sénat dans sa grande sagesse ne peut
se dédire sur une telle question et
merci je voudrais insister mais si l'on
collègues je recommande de nouveau faire
preuve de discernement votants cet
amendement merci merci chers collègues
excusez moi je les ai parlé un petit peu
trop
malin rapporteur
n'est pas utilisée tout mon temps pour
faire contrepoids monsieur le président
c'est un avis défavorable qui a été émis
par la commission qui a estimé que la
prise en compte de ces éléments étaient
normales et d'écouler la procédure
devant la cour d'assises quand bien même
il est vrai que nous avions voté cet
amendement lorsqu'il était passé devant
notre hémicycle précédemment
merci monsieur le ministre
d'amendements monsieur le président pour
les raisons suivantes en réalité cette
disposition sous entend qu'une femme
battue serait pénalement irresponsable
par exemple si elle tue l'auteur des
violences dont elle est elle-même la
victime et même lorsque les conditions
du trouble mental de la contrainte de la
légitime défense ne seraient pas
remplies
je ne peux évidemment pas cautionner un
tel message et nous devons tout faire
pour que ces victimes déposent plainte
qu'elle soit évidemment protéger comme
il se doit mais nous ne devons pas les
inciter à faire justice elle-même voilà
j'ai été court je pense mais très clair
elles sont là encore des questions de
principes qui sont intangibles merci
monsieur ministre main broyée
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
rappeler qu'il ya cinq mois à l'occasion
de l'examen de ce texte nous avions voté
pour ce texte quel message aujourd'hui
nous allons envoyer aux victimes si nous
rejetons ce que nous avons voté hier
alors même que l'actualité juridique
nous a donné raison je me permets de
vous le rappeler le tribunal a reconnu
pour la première fois le syndrome de la
femme battue au delà personnes battues à
l'occasion de la faire cogiter tout à
l'heure et la personne a été condamnée
mais sa peine a été atténuée alors même
que pour les avocates elles se sont
appuyés sur nos débats dans leurs
plaidoiries
alors même que de nombreux français ont
salué la prise de position du sénat je
respecte bien sûr les convictions de
chacun d'entre vous mais faisons preuve
de cohérence avec le syndrome de la
femme battue reconnu en psychiatrie nous
sommes bien face à une altération du
jugement certains évoquent évoque le
permis de tuer c'est entièrement faux ce
n'était en aucun cas un permis de tuer
nous pourrions dans ce cas lister toutes
les irresponsabilité pénale est
considéré qu'elles constituent des
permis de tuer je vous rappelle mes
chers collègues dans notre droit n'est
pas un pénalement responsable la
personne qui était atteinte au moment
des faits d'un trouble psychique ou
neuropsychique ayant aboli son
discernement ou le contrôle de ses actes
pouvons-nous parler d'un permis de tuer
bien sûr que non mais faisons en sorte
de reconnaître une réalité il y à des
situations où les femmes et parfois des
hommes qui suite à des violences
inqualifiables et répétés ont leur
jugement altéré ça dure depuis des
années ça s'appelle aussi l'emprise je
vous propose donc de préciser un autre
loi que l'impact des violences
conjugales devra être pris en compte
certains peuvent me répondre que c'est
déjà le cas ce n'est pas le cas
inscrivant le symboliquement noir sur
blanc dans la loi il y adeux il en va de
notre responsabilité au nom des victimes
car nous parlons bien de victimes et je
répète monsieur le monsieur le ministre
vous venez de dire on ne juge pas les
fous mais doit-on juger sans en parler
sans le mettre dans la loi des personnes
qui en raison des coups répétés ont eu
leur jugement altéré elles ne sont pas
irresponsables mais ce sont des victimes
ça s'appelle le syndrome de la femme
battue faisons en sorte qu'ils entrent
dans notre droit djakolaj monsieur
ministre
il est absolument faux
de dire ici
que les juridictions ne prennent pas en
compte la situation des femmes auteurs
de violence sur leur conjoint
lorsqu'elles ont été elle même victime
de violences je ne sais pas où vous êtes
allé chercher ça en tous les cas pas
dans les tribunaux mais c'est pas vrai
vous dites ça commence à partir de tels
procès mais pardon quel est le juge et
quels sont les jurés qui resterait
insensible à la situation d'une femme
qui tuerait son conjoint parce que
pendant 20 ans elle a été elle-même
victime de violence au quotidien ce que
vous dites est faux et c'est un fort
message qui est envoyé bien sûr que les
juridictions sont sensibles à cela
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire les juges
ils doivent mettre en évidence la
personnalité
de l'auteur pour arriver à une décision
qui prend en compte la personnalisation
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle et
naturellement dans un curriculum vitae
ont fait la différence entre une femme
qui viendrait à tuer quelqu'un dans le
cadre d'un crime crapuleux et une femme
qui le ferait pas ce qu'elles ont peu
plus parce qu'elle est tabou parce
qu'elle est frappé régulièrement et
injuriée on dit n'importe quoi quand on
dit que c'est à compter de tels procès
qu'en réalité les choses sont devenues
différentes ça n'est pas vrai il est
faux de le dire et dire qu une femme
battue à raison du fait qu'elles aient
battu
doit bénéficier de ce que vous proposez
c'est envoyer 1 bien bien bien mauvais
message en réalité les juges ils savent
parfaitement comment fonctionne j'allais
dire la vie des êtres et ils la prennent
en considération
c'est tout à leur honneur merci monsieur
le ministre dont je les envoie à
l'amendement 2 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée
à l'article de trois amendements
identiques le 9 monsieur soeur
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
garde des sceaux mes chers collègues
nous sommes très clairs il fallait
changer l'article 1 et il fallait
adopter la nouvelle rédaction de
l'article
1 nous aurions préféré un autre sinon
nous nous rallions à celle du
gouvernement mais nous nous rallions
aussi à celle de la commission forte que
les deux premières et été adopté en
revanche nous sommes totalement contre
l'article 2 parce que là cycle 1 suffi à
changer comme il le faut la législation
l'article 2 introduit beaucoup de
confusion
d'ambiguïtés et de difficultés
d'adaptation
en effet il n'est plus question de la
consommation de substances avec cet
article 2 dans l'intention de commettre
un délit mais d'une consommation qui
conduit à commettre un délit ou un crime
ainsi vous cherchez à distinguer la
consommation de substances psychoactives
des actes que l'individu accomplira sous
leur emprise tout en souffrant d'une
pathologie ou de troubles psychiatriques
qui préexiste ou non au fait en gros on
appliquera certes l'article 122-1 du
code pénal en déclarant l'
irresponsabilité pénale en raison d'une
d'un abolition du discernement mais on
cherchera à savoir si avant de commettre
les faits leur auraient leur auteur
n'aurait pas cherché à se placer dans
cette situation
deux objections d'abord ce dispositif
risque difficile à appliquer les
victimes et les parties civiles auront
du mal à faire valoir qu'un tel délit a
été commis ensuite cet article
concerneraient des cas très marginaux
selon l'étude d'impact et l'avis du
conseil d'état il s'appliquerait donc
très rarement néanmoins son adoption
amènerait à pénaliser et à condamner des
personnes dont on considère aujourd'hui
qu'il souffrait d'une abolition totale
du discernement au moment des faits vous
m'auriez monivong leur la structure du
droit en matière d'abolition du
discernement sans toutefois l'assumé
pleinement monsieur le président c'est
pourquoi nous demandons la suprématie
chers collègues le 38 la présidente à ça
si les merci monsieur le président dans
la suite de ce que vient de dire le pré
le monsieur sur cet article donc insère
dans le code pénal de nouvelle
infraction intentionnelle l'atteinte à
la vie résultant d'une intoxication
volontaire et l'atteinte à l'intégrité
de la personne en résultant d'une
intoxication volontaire alors de
nombreuses questions se posent
lorsqu'on connaît les effets les
réactions multiples qu'engendre la prise
de toxiques une des caractéristiques
constante de tous les états produits
résident dans la perte d'ancrage avec le
réel ce qui est en parfaite
contradiction avec l'idée de
responsabilisation la caractérisation de
ces nouvelles infractions présage la
gestion d'une véritable usine à gaz en
perspective pour les magistrats et
experts judiciaires de leur propre aveu
nous réitérons donc avec cet amendement
d'autres attachement au principe suivant
lequel l'abolition du discernement au
moment de l'acte et exclusive de
l'intention au sens du droit pénal
considérant qu'il ne peut y avoir des
exceptions à ce principe
sans remettre en cause l'édifice pénal
et en ce sens nous partageons l'avis de
la commission présidée par dominique
raimbourg et philippe houillon sur
l'irresponsabilité pénale mis en place
par l'ancienne garde des sceaux
cette commission avait après plusieurs
mois de travaux concluent à l'innocuité
d'une réforme dans ce domaine dans son
rapport qui a été remis rap mais en
février 2021 merci le 72 monsieur
benachenhou d'antiques pourri sans
reprendre les arguments développés
parfaitement bien par monsieur et madame
à ça si je rajouterais de petites choses
cet article 2 pour nous fragilise de
nouveau le système du droit pénal comme
l'article 1 contre lequel nous nous
sommes
prononcés qui malheureusement a été
votée parce qu'ils présupposent en plus
de tout ce qui a été dit il présuppose
en fait la connaissance par le mis en
cause des effets biologiques des
produits dont ils ne pourraient à moins
d'être lui-même experts d'ailleurs
connaître les effets la pratique serait
bien trop aléatoire dans la réalité
comment caractériser la prise j'ouvre
les guillemets manifestement excessive
de substance psycho actifs ou le fait
qu'une personne avait connaissance du
fait que cette consommation était
susceptible de le conduire à commettre
des atteintes à la vie ou à l'intégrité
d'autrui si on ne présuppose pas une
connaissance parfaite des mises en cause
surtout des effets biologiques des
produits qui va être amené des effets
des produits qu'il va être amené à
prendre je vais citer un exemple j'en
dis si tu es un grand nombre y hier je
vais en citer un autre
deux verres d'alcool dans un certain
état de santé ne perturbera pas
forcément un individu mais un verre peut
le perturber s'il a été privé de sommeil
ou selon l'état de fatigue dans lequel
il se trouve il faudrait une
connaissance parfaite de sa réaction à
la prise d'un certain nombre de produits
pour savoir juger si c'est une prise
manifestement excessive ou pas la
position de suppression de l'article
s'inscrit en fait aussi dans la ligne du
rapport qui a été cité de la mission sur
les responsabilités pénales qui a été
menée par dominique raimbourg et
philippe houillon et qui a été remise au
garde des sceaux leva 3 avril 2000 a
ainsi que sur celles de nos travaux de
printemps dernier qui préconisait je
vous le rappelle cher collègue de
laisser en l'état l'article 122-1 du
code pénal c'est pour cela que nous
demandons la suppression de cet article
merci maman à porter
merci monsieur président quelques mots
d'explication sur certains articles 2 de
quelques à parlons nous mais je
laisserai bien évidemment monsieur le
garde des sceaux de développer plus
avant puisque c'est l'article qui a été
déposé par le gouvernement
nous parlons de l'hypothèse dans
laquelle quelqu'un prend des substances
dites psychoactives aller admettons deux
bouteilles de whisky dont il ne peut
ignorer les effets que ces substances
peuvent avoir mettant en danger et
éventuellement la vie d autrui et comme
elle sous l'effet de ces substances
les violences
même arrive à tuer quelqu'un sous
l'effet de ces violences on boit deux
bouteilles de whisky on prend sa voiture
on écrase quelqu'un dans ces conditions
il est possible que l'irresponsabilité
pénale soit constatée car l'effet de
l'alcool en l'occurrence ne permet pas
d'avoir un discernement et il est abolie
totalement ce qui va être incriminé et
ce qui peut être puni sous réserve bien
sûr et je suis là dessus un certain
nombre de propos qui ont été tenus par
ceux qui présentent les amendements se
réserve bien sûr qu'on puisse prouver
l'ensemble des éléments constitutifs de
l'infraction c'est à dire la
connaissance de la mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui potentiel du fait de
prendre ces substances psycho actives
dans ces conditions l'acte lui même ne
sera pas jugée car l'irresponsabilité
pénale sera constatée mais la prise des
substances sera l incriminé et pourra
donner lieu à condamnation voilà quel
est l'article brièvement résumé qui a
été soumis à la commission et que la
commission a accepté et je vous demande
dans ces conditions et bien de rendre un
avis défavorable sur les amendements
merci monsieur maistre
parle très peu de chose à rajouter à ce
que vient de dire excellemment madame la
rapporteure cet article 2 il dit en
réalité
celui dont le discernement était aboli à
raison d'une pathologie mentale par
exemple
et ya rien à dire qu'on ne juge pas les
fous dans notre pays on le faisait tous
au moyen âge et ce serait une régression
sociétal considérable que d'envisager
autre chose c'est une ligne rouge que
personne ne veut franchir et puis la
situation de quelqu'un qui se retrouvent
sans discernement à raison d'un
comportement positif
qu'il a lui même généré
dans cette situation et il faut le dire
exceptionnellement rare ces deux
exemples depuis 40 ans mais tout de même
il fallait intervenir parce que il ya
l'émotion naturellement suscité par la
sphère halimi
mais légiférer après l'émotion ça ne
signifie pas légiférer n'importe comment
ça veut dire légiférer dans le cadre de
nos règles et des règles de droit c'est
naturellement la société qui fait
évoluer le droit et pas l'inversé il y
avait également la pelle si vous me
permettez cette familiarité lancé par la
cour de cassation notamment par l'avocat
général qui requiert dans cette affaire
et qui dit nous ne pouvons pas aller là
où le législateur ne nous permet pas
d'aller il y avait ce que l'on appelle
déteste cette expression mais je la
reprends à mon compte un trou dans la
raquette il fallait le combler c'est la
raison pour le port pour laquelle il ya
ce texte et je les dis moi j'ai consulté
beaucoup beaucoup pour ne pas franchir
les lignes qui sont infranchissables et
nous avons trouvé cette solution je
remercie la commission des lois du sénat
d'être d'accord on peut pas examiner de
la même façon ce serait inéquitable
celui qui est un malade mental et qui le
pauvre n'est responsable de rien et
celui qui se met dans une situation
telle que sa raison peu chanceux les et
que son discernement peut s'enfuir celui
là il a une vraie responsabilité je l'
ai dit tout à l'heure s'agissant de
stupéfiants c'est un an d'emprisonnement
aucun procureur j'aurai en l'état actuel
de la législation organise un procès
vous imaginez que l'on faille que l'on
fasse venir pardonnez-moi les victime
d'un homicide à l'audience
correctionnelle un en prison
et le condamné peut peut regarder les
victimes en disant mais même pas mal ça
ce n'est tellement pas concevable que ça
ne se fait pas et donc nous on a voulu
cette infraction claire nette et précise
pour qu'il y ait une responsabilité
j'ajoute que cet article 2 permet
naturellement la constitution de partie
civile des victimes du crime qui lui ne
pourra pas être jugé parce que nous
avons quand même constat qui est celui
de l'irresponsabilité ce texte il est me
semble-t-il équilibré ils comblent le
vide juridique qui existaient et même
vous avez raison monsieur le sénateur si
c'est un cas tous les quarante ans on ne
pouvait pas rester les bras ballants
face au constat jurisprudentielle il
s'imposait à nous vous savez le texte de
la pma c'est parfois des situations
une situation par an et est encore quand
elle arrive et pourtant il fallait
naturellement légiférer pardon pour
cette analogie mais je pense que nous
sommes au rendez vous de nos obligations
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
évidemment je suis totalement opposé aux
amendements que vous avez présenté
vous me montrez votre scepticisme madame
la présidente mais au fond vous saviez
que je ne pouvais pas être d'accord avec
vous parce que c'est toute
l'architecturé de ce texte
franchement quelqu'un qui a consommé des
produits stupéfiants et qui tue et qui
s'en sort au motif au fond que il a
consommé des produits stupéfiants il ya
quelque chose qui colle pas là ni en
équité ni en justice c'est quelque chose
que nous avons souhaité réparer
merci monsieur ministre donc je mets on
voit les trois amendements identiques le
neuf le 38 72 avec deux avis
défavorables qui et pour
qui et contre qui s'abstient ils ne sont
pas adopté l'amendement 87 du
gouvernement de monsieur ministre
le président très rapidement la
commission était d'accord avec le
gouvernement et pourquoi donc s'est elle
arrêtée en si bon chemin pour ne pas
accepter dans les infractions que nous
visons à l'article 2 l'incendié
volontaire portant atteintes aux
personnes d'abord je voudrais vous dire
deux choses à ce propos certes il s'agit
d'une atteinte aux biens dans la
classification mais comme il s'agit
d'une atteinte aux biens ayant des
conséquences sur les personnes s'est
jugée comme un crime et c'est en réalité
une atteinte aux personnes en terme de
gravité et en termes de pénalité c'est
la première chose que j'entends vous
dire la deuxième c'est que je suis allée
volontiers vers cette infraction parce
que nous savons qu autour des incendies
il y as souvent en tous les cas parfois
en tous les cas pas exceptionnellement
loin s'en faut des problématiques
d'ordre psychiatrique il ya chez les
incendiaires chez certains d'entre eux
un certain nombre de vraies difficultés
qu'on retrouve dans les expertises c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai souhaité
que cette infraction qui est une
infraction grave
soit prise en compte dans l'article 2
merci en allant à porter
le président eh bien monsieur le garde
des sceaux la commission de la pas
souhaité pour des raisons qui sont
facilement explicable tout simplement la
commission a préféré s'en tenir aux
atteintes volontaires à la personne ou
aux atteintes involontaires à la
personne dans l' incendie qui commet des
victimes le fait principal c'est le fait
d'incendier les victimes sont de la
conséquences possibles de cet incendie
donc nous avons préféré sur cet article
qui est quelque peu de dérogatoire nous
en tenir aux atteintes à la personne en
évitant les atteintes aux biens même si
elles peuvent découler sur une atteinte
aux victimes donc c'est un avis
défavorable monsieur le garde des sceaux
de nous ne pouvons pas être d'accord
tout le temps merci donc je me revois
l'amendement 87 de gouvernement avec un
avis défavorable la commission qui est
pour
et qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adoptée je
mets souvent à l'article 2 qui est pour
l'article 2 qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
[Musique]